in texas this morning the border patrol
is allowing asylum seekers to cross into
the u.s
from mexico to have their requests
processed
we went to the border and discovered
that some asylum seekers
who have waited years to press their
claims say recent rule changes
have actually put them at the back of
the line again
president biden reversed the trump
administration's remain in mexico policy
maria villarreal is in brownsville texas
with how the new policy has created
dueling approaches among would-be
migrants in mexico
mileah good morning well good morning
anthony during the trump administration
getting an asylum hearing was
nearly impossible and even though the
biden administration has done away with
this policy
information and answers are hard to come
by right now but to truly understand
what is at stake here you have to take a
look at this issue from both sides of
this border
in matamoros mexico this massive tent
town is home to nearly a thousand
migrants
these are the families that followed the
rules they crossed into the u.s through
a checkpoint
and were sent back to mexico to wait for
their asylum cases to be heard
some have been here for two years sam
bishop is an army veteran providing
essential medical help and other
services for these migrants
people's daily lives are here and
they've been here for so long that
they've like anywhere else they've been
able to establish and
and and function yeah it's a microcosm
of a real normal
functioning city we're not allowed
inside the camp so we talked to pearla
vargas through the fence
she and her daughter had to wait in
mexico for a year and a half but are
hopeful
her case will finally get heard through
the remaining mexico policy more than 70
000 people were sent to mexico to await
asylum hearings
creating a bottleneck in cases during
the trump administration
while those people wait in limbo others
are crossing the border illegally and
taking their chances with the new
administration
over the border in brownsville texas we
met up with one of the moms in this
group who says they crossed the river
on a raft paying a smuggler 800 dollars
for two people
they asked for asylum when they were
picked up by border patrol
that process begins with a cova test and
a negative result
means they are released into the united
states to wait for a hearing
andrea rudnick is with team brownsville
a grassroots organization working to
help families gain asylum
they're just choosing at this point not
to even go through the process
that's right because because the word
has gotten out
that families with young children are
getting across and getting released to
go on to those families
i mean it's catch and release all over
again yes it is
we're trying not to use those words but
yes it is while the administration
and congress work through legislation
and mexican officials say they don't
have the resources to care for families
like this
anymore people like rudnick and her
organization
are left trying to fill the gaps for
team brownsville
our motto has always been meeting the
needs
one family at a time and that's really
all i can think about i can't think
about
ten thousand people a hundred thousand
people a million people
today just 25 people will be allowed to
cross this border and finish out their
asylum cases in the u.s and that number
is expected to grow
over the next few weeks but just to
point out the trump administration did
believe
catch and release didn't work because
families wouldn't show up to court but
there is
evidence that shows up to 96 percent of
the families that are requesting asylum
do show up to their court hearings gail
maria thank you very much